hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting game that was played
yesterday in assessment in Croatia was a
simultaneous exhibition held by reigning
Croatian champion Grandmaster madam
Basia touch and with the black pieces
my nephew Philip Marty so you might have
heard of them already we already showed
one game where he played in a
simultaneous exhibition against Garak as
part of if you haven't I will put a link
to it in the description below it will
be the first thing you will see really a
really an interesting game and also I
will put also below that a game where
Philips father Goren Marcus played
against Garry Kasparov so yeah if you
haven't seen that do check it out as
well so that being said let's check out
the game and also I've seen in the
previous video where whenever I'm doing
a simultaneous exhibition video yes the
the person holding the simultaneous
exhibition always has the white pieces
on all boards so just to set that
straight so Martin opens whit Knight to
f3 the rate the opening is on the board
Phillip replies with Knight of 6 we have
c4 c5 so going symmetrical and g3 we
have Knight to c6 by Phillip Bishop to
g2 and then our v6 Phillip is now
preparing to fianchetto the light square
bishop the counter modern slide square
bishop we have castles and now Bishop to
b7 so this is a fairly standard stuff
Knight to c3 we have e 6 and now b3
Martin prepare stuff in get to the dark
square Bishop as well we have Bishop to
e7 by Phillip and now Bishop to b2 in
catering the other bishop as well
and now just castles we have III by
Martin and now D 6 and D for now
expanding in the center
and now there is one game where look to
see it was played also Knight also see
capture sandy for is a non move but
Queen to d7 it's a new move so it is as
of move 10 that we have a completely new
game so Martin continues developing with
Queen e2 connecting rooks with rook a to
d8 and now rook F to d1 putting a rook
and well perhaps soon to be open file
and here Phil plays a six
another way to three the position would
be to prevent the white from pushing d5
so you could push d5 yourself point
being that old
the trades in the center I do favor
black you you do get a very nice Center
however it is still to be decided
whether those are strong or weak bones
but that's one way to go about the
position Philippines that goes a six
takes away the b5 square from the night
also in the future he might have some b5
ideas and now Myron pushes d5 which is
of course what he wants to do because he
wants to open up this dark square Bishop
diagonal and now if you capture
capturing doesn't really do much for
black captures captures captures
captures and now the knight doesn't have
be v e5 square is covered by white so
you have to go back either b8 or a five
and well this d5 point is really just a
bone in blacks throat it's really
paralyzing blacks entire position
so instead Phillip goes Knight to a5 now
adds another attacker to the d5 square
but now II for adding another defender
the ship to h3 is also interesting since
the the the e6 pawn is pinned and might
also be a viable option okay II for
strengthening the center and now II five
Philippi decides to close the center we
have Knights to h4 maybe with ideas of
bringing the night over to f5 and also
preparing this ff4 move as now the
diagonal of the dark square Bishop is
again quote so we won't open it up with
f4 so King to h8 by Phillip even the
night lands here g6 field is preparing
g6 so he doesn't want Knight to h6 to
come with check
we have Knight to f5 as planned and now
g6 so what do you play here both your
choo-choo grabs the bishop with Knight
captures on e7 Queen captures and now f4
so this is a makes perfect sense this
will open up the bishops diagonal black
can never capture as the king is on h8
we have Knight back to d7 now now if
Martin captures field wants to bring a
knife to e5 play King back to g8 on pin
and well I just continue playing the
game so here we have Queen to c2 and
here you have a few options of how you
can continue playing the game Knight to
a4 is one option making black worry
about the b6 pawn but mainly it's
between rook to f1 getting group to F
one playing well a nice rook the rook f1
rook f2 and then bringing the other
Brooke over to f1 maybe push f5 this is
one way to play it but most she decides
to play on the Queen side instead he
plays Queen to c2 guards the b3 pawn and
prepares a 3 so the B three ponies
guarded
we have ff6 I feel strength in the
center even further so now the dark
square bishop really is not a problem
and now a three by Myron
we have rook to b8 by philipp preparing
to move the bishop and now he wants to
start playing on the Queen side we have
night Stewie - now opening up the dark
square bishop and now b5 we have rook a
to be one and now comes the bush of the
c8 opening up the the B file for the
rook we have Bishop to c3 pushing back
the night but now before we have a cat
person before seek a person before
Bishop back to be - and now Knight the
c5 and all of a sudden you can see that
it's now black who is dictating the tone
of the battle the b3 pawn is under
attack you have to defend it
there is only one move to defend it nice
to see one
so the the b3 phone is now nicely
defended and now Bishop to g4 attacking
the rook
also activating the bishop will rook to
e1 and now Queen to a7 now threatening
all sorts of nasty discoveries so Martin
of course moves the King King h1 and now
King back to g8 getting away from the
from the dark square bishop diagonal we
have worked a 1 now attacking the knight
and the Queen to c7 so here Philips plan
will be to move the knight and start
pushing this pawn get this one to be 3
and so on so with f5 Mari now tries to
open up the position on the King side
but now g5 Phelps's no we are not
opening up the position on the Kings
side and rook to e3 the rook here will
be very helpful in the defense of the
third-ranked primarily the b3 pawn and
now as you know Vasily Ranchi once said
the hardest move to find is with the
knight back so night 8 and b7 preparing
making way for this a pawn to be pushed
we have h3 pushing the bishop back
bishop h4 and now g4 the Shabak to en by
phil
but this really just helps Philip as he
needs another protector of the a
Foursquare so it will support a five a
four with age four by Myron now with
ideas of bringing the rocker maybe maybe
bringing Queen to h2 may be captures
maybe some threats along the along the H
file but Phil just calmly plays h6 we
have looked at h3 and the now rook to f7
this will be a useful defender along the
seventh rank and also if needed if
Martin does bust open the position on
the King side maybe even created an
escape route for the king
we have Knight to e2 and now comes a
five so a four is coming we have night
the g3 by Myron and now comes Luke the
h7 sort of a safety move even though a a
four is perfectly playable right away
but okay rook to h7 we have Bishop the
f3 now with maybe with ideas of bringing
the Queen over to h2 and now comes a
four so okay now you don't want to allow
a three so or even a cap for some be
three so Abby captures on a four and now
you cannot recapture right away the pawn
is guarded twice so b3 first Queen to h2
and now comes Knight the d3 an excellent
move threatening the bishop but also
threatening Knight f4 because the rip
rook is strapped on h3 so Queen d2 by
Myron making room for the rook and h2 if
if the rook is attacked but now just
Knight captures on b2 Queen captures and
B to end eliminating the c4 pawn Queen
captures on c4 and now white white is
definitely in trouble here Martin starts
pushing the a pawn but Phillip finds a
very nice way how to deal with the
position night the c5 then out the
knight is now coming to a four will
attack the Queen and then the pawn will
be able to advance further so a six but
just nights the a for this not only
attacks the Queen but also blocks the
rooks defense of the pawn here and you
don't ever have to worry about a 7
because the rook from the seventh rank
also guards h7 so here if you move the
Queen it's just game or if let's say
Queen d2 just b2 is coming rook to be
one and now Queen a two attacks the rook
Queen c2 or D
three doesn't matter Knight to c3 is
coming and that's it the rock is under
attack if you capture rook then if you
capture the night Queen captures rook
and it's game over
so here Myron decides he had he has to
do something
rook captures on a4 he gives up the
exchange Queen captures on a4 and now H
captures an g5 and now although this
perfectly playable Philip decides that
the clothes to keep it closed not giving
him any any chance for for counter play
so madam pushes f6 he has to try
something otherwise he's just dead lost
so Queen - a - Philip offers a queen
trade and he will get a nice pass pawn
an A - Marvin of course cannot afford
that rook the h2 and now Phil just
calmly trades Queen captures rook
captures and b2 and now Bishop to g6
putting pressure putting pressure on the
e4 pawn here and it will be hard for
whites to activate his pieces so King G
- the King starts coming into the game
looked the c7 now with ideas of rook C
to check which is just the game over so
disrupted d1 preventing and now rook to
a 7 with ideas of picking up the pawn
and going to row K - so what do you what
do you do here we have buffer back to e
- you could cap from b3 but that I mean
that doesn't really do anything for you
you're still down the exchange so Martin
has to keep things complicated Bishop to
e2 defending on a6 and now look the b4
again with a double attack on the e4
pawn king ef3 defending now rook f7
preparing to win df7 point d f6 pawn
with check King III getting out of the
way and now rook back to c7 preparing
rook the c3 would check with Bishop to
d3 and now king f7 now the king will
gobble up the f6 pawn we have Knights to
f1 now this can be played as both the
king and the bishop are guarding the e4
pawn now just King captures on f6 here
we have Knights to d2 now there's really
not much to play here for white he's
attacking the b3 pawn and here Phillip
plate rook the c3 defending the b3 pawn
and really is just a very unpleasant
move for white and it's hard to define
the move here for
white this isn't this is not really an
option if you ever push this just broke
to a four and we even have a video of
this moment recorded by his father
Philip March so here we have it let's
just enjoy that for a second here you
will see how how how hard how difficult
the position is and how long it took for
Martin to find even what to play in this
position so here's the video let's just
enjoy it there you can see Phil if one
of the last two remain playing or maybe
maybe even the last I don't know but
yeah it's it's a really complicated
position you can see if you've just
played the rook the c3 and there there's
just no move to be played so really
really exciting stuff
you can see that his father's hand is
really shaking his father I think his
father is more nervous than Phillip here
yes not not an easy position to make a
move
so there we have kink the e2 here and
pins and he continues to move away from
the board which probably means that
there were some other boards in play or
maybe he just likes it likes to walk
around but you know III do not have this
information but okay King to e2 was
played and now comes look back to c7 by
Phillip here a lot of moves were
possible here instead of rock c7 but
Phillip knows that this this will not do
anything for white and he he still has
this position so he allows root chakras
on v3 rook captures Knight captures and
now h5 now Phillip continues play on the
Kings side G captures with Bishop
captures with check King III and now g4
we have nice the a5 hoping for some
maybe night be 7 or night to c6 action
maybe if you can get the pond to a 7
it could be something but g3 and now the
pawn and the Bishop prevented or the
White King from from getting near the
pond so Bishop the f1 preventing a point
to g2 but now rook the c3 with check now
Phillip uses this check maneuver to get
behind the passed pawn and the night saw
came to d2 look back the a3 now if you
push it just captures and you guard the
queening square so it's not a problem
Knight to c6 and here yes you can
capture on e6 you can do a lot of things
Phillips played Bishop to f3 he prepares
to put it upon to g2 we have a 7 by boss
heritage and here any move wins here
even well you could have even this is a
something I forgot to mention after
Knight to c6
you can even capture here it doesn't
really matter if the bishop captures
because the bishop needs to guard the
queening square so that was also
possible but ok if you look when Bishop
to f3
we have a 7 and here Phillip just played
Bishop characters
before you could push g2 right away but
Phil played Bishop captures a knife on
e4 and he will he would have probably
captured on d5 before pushing g2 as well
because that's just how he rolls and
yeah it was in this position on most
sixty-seven that reigning a champion of
Croatia Grandmaster madam Basia CH
resigned the game and this is I believe
Philips first official victory against a
grandmaster
so congratulations Phillip really an
impressive game and yeah I do hope you
enjoyed it like I said do check out do
check out I feel this game against Garry
Kasparov if you haven't it will be the
first link in the description below and
also if you have the time check out
Philips father's game against Garry
Kasparov because that's also also very
very interesting so our congratulations
once again to Philip so far I was able
to beat Philip every time I played him
in our clock championship but I don't
know next time it might be might be a
real a real mess so we'll see how it
goes
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Stephen
Merchant
Andrew Maha Walt and matthew Miller for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous video Sarah
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the of the
Morphy saga of course the Tata Steel a
masters edition and the Women's World
Chess Championship and of course
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day